the problem with getting natural
immunity from having the disease itself
is that some naturally acquired
infections can cause serious
complications or may even be deadly
for example polio can result in
permanent paralysis or death
measles can cause swelling of the brain
resulting in permanent brain damage or
death especially in children under age
five
and whooping cough also known as
pertussis can cause complications such
as pneumonia slowed or stopped breathing
and death especially in babies under one
year of age
while symptoms may not be severe in all
people it's not possible to know who
will be affected enough to become very
ill or even die